this is the technical difficulties were
playing citation needed joining me today
he reads books you know it's Chris Joel
everybody's favorite going around going
random and of course the thing you must
not do if the ape is enraged is the
Macarena muff about YouTube o in front
of me I've got an article from Wikipedia
and these folks can't see it every fact
that right is a point and a ding and the
special prize for good answers which is
and today we are talking about Charles
Blondin kisses exactly nothing to go on
the way I pronounce that gives you a bit
of a a bit of a hint say yes Charles
Wanda also known as the great blunder
did he do something with hot-air
balloons that something you know that I
know so sudden man II saw a name isn't
it yeah I know France did hot-air
balloons that was the Montgolfier
brothers right France did he's right you
know he's not wrong he's not wrong he's
not yet in the back of your mind the
phrase is how do I say he's wrong yeah
Chevalier Blanc none or the great
blonder magician um certainly that sort
of entertainer but not that sort of man
oh is he like that bit in Ocean's eleven
with the acrobatics to steal the money
from the vault we all have a very
specific acrobatic trick here something
it's something that you've been wasn't
like Henry the no we're having the false
favorite Acrobat he's Henry the fourth I
might be able to admit evil said their
apology I might have got the wrong wrong
King there who's who was known for a
Whistler tumbling a fart
that was his act and he was knighted
because the King thought it was so funny
apparently Roland you're not getting
point to this but you are right this was
King Henry the second Henry says in
medieval times
a medieval flatulence who each year in
exchange for 30 acres of land was
obliged to perform a jump a whistle and
a foul
for flattery list yes no I know this
because Wikipedia has a list of
flatulence yes what wasn't he actually
doing he wasn't actually breaking wind
he was that this is gonna be grim he was
able to suck wind in and then blow it
out again through muscle power
I assumed and because that was
technically a question I asked you
getting the point we are looking for a
specific acrobatic act that Charles
Blondin was face no wine D wine before
Lee fabric thing my boy Timothy
my fine trampled Marlene trampled
trampoline know the the the higher up
walk along II yeah it's either one that
war between big buildings no bullet
patty yes this was French yes yeah
thanks Anne in Philly pitty Pat you in
the Heartbreakers brother right it is
the the Waukee long II yeah not for me
down correct the elastomer string he was
a tightrope walker he came up with the
idea to cross a certain thing on a
tightrope Oh thing he falls I'm not
allowing you thingy for Niagara that's
the one I'm singing you're absolutely
right at Niagara for men why D dangerous
why default we're not tall Falls
Victoria curve is good me like that oh
the waterfall backwards
he don't want to rub it the wrong way
doing what
why is no one else's bother about me
that positive drown the fish a drownded
miss him fine with it
you should have seen Noah trying to load
them onto the ark did not like they get
the fish a long time ago yeah you're
absolutely right he was the first to
cross Niagara why would he do insult it
or something to cross Niagara Falls
on a tightrope what did he then go back
and do fetch the other end of the rope
and walk back with it to sing it some
other act on the tightrope whistle
tumble faster
famous midair Tyra walking flat cellist
however and there was some theatrical
variations on the idea of when he wore
something his wife um he carries manager
I think no idea of carrying persons told
something to give you the point there um
it's that in case he had any border
issues at the other end if no it's in
case he wasn't getting a big enough cup
negotiate with you degree quick though
yeah also in a sack on stilts not at the
same time uh and also she was in a sack
yes he was in a sack how did he how did
he talk rot walk in the sack oh right
with you sorry yeah
sack racing across the tire I would
define every bite over little people
think about the overtaking does that
mean they next did an egg and spoon race
yeah Agra falls oh we're talking
tightrope sport race spot spots there
Matt Matt Matt you are so close
unbelievably the word egg is the
accurate one in there what did he do in
the middle of a tightrope over Niagara
Falls in about 1860 fry are my omelet Oh
II I was saying that ate and omelette on
a tightrope in the middle of Niagara
Falls what on what well the total pan
yeah all right not bad but what you know
cuz you got that means a heat source so
you got to have a little cooking stove
or something out balanced on but what's
that balanced on is that good Sam's how
did he carry anything and everything and
up what else I mean that is the trick
that is being paid to do that is why
it's impressive go he also stood on a
chair with one chair leg on the rope on
the meters above above the water how big
is this wire by the way well while we're
on it quite long because it has to go
across Niagara Falls what's the diameter
of this wire she's one oh no oh oh just
slices of feet I mean well I'd like you
all to do at this point is to gesture at
how big you think this wire is so what
thickness one yeah yeah big that big
have you just just made that whatever
happens to be the size of your no no I'm
thinking a cable for I'm thinking how
big it would be for your feet to
comfortably sit on and be a tower so it
can't be much bigger than about that I
wouldn't yeah Gary's basic got it
spot-on
aged a bit centimeters you're right
balls for this I can't actually see them
undo the egg I'd rather they always
close to tubes I could witness how good
the omelet was I'm sorry if he's gonna
show up oh I'm gonna get picky as well
it's gonna be like Saturday kitchen yeah
they doing yes I do in a minute that's a
reference enough many people are gonna
get it now there is a sentence of this
article
obviously at this point he was born in
France he's moved to the US to do this
sort of thing while in the US he married
someone called Charlotte Lawrence what's
strange about that
is he a bigamist well we don't know I'll
give you the point because the phrase
here is while in the u.s. he married a
second wife that
it's slightly earlier it says he first
he married Marie blonde Cherie and it is
not known what happened to his French
family after he went to America so I
will give you the point it's quite
possible that he divorced her or that
something else happened it's not
recorded in he imagined being his first
wife thinking new husband's disappeared
never to be heard of again picking up
Lomond and Cielo from page man cooks egg
over Niagara Falls and BA oh yeah it was
definitely front page worthy oh yeah
what this isn't this is London came back
to Europe lived in the UK retired for a
while and then made a reappearance in
the sort of manner you'd expect stars
who are in need of money to do this I'm
a celebrity something that existed at
the end of the 19th century and still
exists now aunt oh yes right he appeared
in Jack and the Beanstalk at the Crystal
Palace no Crystal Palace at the Crystal
Palace I'm going to guess that what he
did his tightrope act on was maybe the
Beanstalk I'm gonna suggest that might
be it's not it's not recorded here there
was a front end of the Punto horse while
on the Beanstalk Oh back-end not a
tightrope you have to put some tightrope
walking in there because this guy's a
one-trick pony when he's out of work
he's picking getting the Washington
where is he on top of the washing
he was so associated with tightrope
walking that what happened to his name
Oh the tightrope became his name a
tightrope walker was called a blunder ah
that's how well-known he was like our
people Google for things going back to
it anything like that guy who was around
in the early 2000s called mr. methane
another one on your list of famous watch
lists yeah see these bits together today
there is also a thing called a blonde an
even now um and it's a bit of industrial
equipment what might it be
safety rig for working at height uh not
not for people
and the sheep working go on Bessie no
grass is a bit long near the cliff man
no not really
that's the valley thing you might need
because companies are putting sheep on
their roof don't they
what if you but if you if you build a
new building you can put the organic
Rouge on there a layer of girl finish
your light and to stop it some companies
want it to be kind of a wild garden but
other companies want it neatly Melina
and they're putting cheap on sheep and
goats on cracking so you might be the
safety I'm free sheep now when is the
last time you put a safety harness on a
sheep Wednesday all I can think is that
I want to change jobs to Ariel Shepherd
what might you need to move on a rope in
a quarry oh yeah you're absolutely right
it's an aerial ropeway
use mulch slight quarry's it's called a
blonde dam after him oh I saw like the
ones in the end of that doesn't spoil
anything like the ends at the end of Get
Carter that kind of thing wait don't :
the sea hands up who's seen Get Carter
the screen down were watching that sir
you're a big man but you're a shape he
does this for a living
touch from guitar there is one other
person I'd like to talk about through
Niagara Falls and from a history of nad
is it was a lady or gentleman went over
in a barrel
you said lady or a gentleman Gary I'll
give you the choice pick one off the
little bell ringing the back of my head
said lady but could be wrong any idea of
the names Annie Edison Taylor born in
1838 end up in Bay City Michigan where
she hoped to become a dance instructor
did she not uh I mean have the point why
not good enough
Gold River
there's nobody wanting to dance there
are no dance schools now why didn't she
saw cook break the mold and start when
Rosa did she absolutely did huh
and then she she traveled all over the
place trying to find work couldn't
finally move back to base City which
means she wanted to secure her later
years financially you have to avoid what
work houses yeah yeah yeah absolutely
right she decided she would be the first
person to ride over Niagara Falls in a
barrel and she does that securing her
future but not putting it at dire risk
she was actually in her sixty we really
yep
using a custom-made barrel why did she
is barrel not like a boat or something
yeah proper it was a proper barrel
that's a good question what is a barrel
designed to do Oh keep water out exactly
it's to keep water in deep booze in and
water out all right man come on it is
meant to be waterproof so the idea is
she's in there in a slightly pressurized
barrel yeah with a heart-shaped pillow
and there was a lid on it there was a
lid on it so right up to the waist
always assumed up that's how I've always
pictured it I've never thought something
like a tub of heads yeah come to think
of it yeah so I know she was she was
stuffed in a barrel um with the top
sealed a little bit of pressure in there
the idea being well she's gonna feel is
darkness darkness darkness plunge thump
thump thump thump thump get out the
other side did she
well you keep asking me the questions
Matt but that's not actually what I'm
here for so let's say she didn't she did
she made it over the falls with nothing
but a small gash on her head uh what did
she say yeah afterwards I mean it was it
was gonna give me the point cuz it
wasn't that sure it was in so few words
but yes if it was with my dying breath I
would caution anyone against attempting
the feat and that's never a great
recommendation for a ride you know but
it's really smart for somebody who's
looking to secure their fame
the one who did it I would sooner walk
up to the mouth of a cannon knowing it
was going to blow me to pieces than make
another trip over the fall and next week
watch me walk up to a cabin at the end
of the show congratulations Chris you in
this one well done you in a small fast
bird that makes clothing for other small
fast birds it's this Taylor Swift with
that we say thank you to Chris Joel to
go German tomorrow okay Tom Scott we'll
see you next time
[Music]